[Musique]
le quartier chinois de montréal a perdu
de sa vitalité pourtant il recèle des
commerces à découvrir et des bâtiments
historiques
le dernier étage de ce bâtiment qui on
le voit avec les enseignes chinoises
sont souvent des bâtiments qui sont
abrités par des associations clanique
donc des étages qui sont réservées à une
famine grande famille ce soit les
langues se soit libye par exemple
donc ils sont propriétaires de ces
bâtiments souvent depuis des générations
[Musique]
un des édifices qui caractérise le
quartier c'est celui ci conçu en 1826 à
l'époque il abritait une école la
british and canadian secours aujourd'hui
il est occupé par le fabricant de
biscuits orientaux et de noé wing en
activité depuis plus de 100 ans
l'immeuble a été vendu en mars on parle
d'un bâtiment qui a 200 ans d'histoire
et à côté de lui parmi les maisons les
plus anciennes du quartier
donc la moitié des bâtiments que vous
voyez ont déjà été achetés par des
développeurs qui souhaitent en faire un
grand projet immobilier la vente oblige
le service de la famille chinoise de
montréal a quitté le local qu'ils
occupaient depuis plus de 30 ans pour
s'établir ailleurs dans le quartier bien
des membres de la communauté craint que
le développement commercial lui valent
héritage culturel du quartier chinois
ça nous inquiète beaucoup parce que
parce que c'est un milieu de lever et
pour les chinois mme surtout pour les
aînés qui parlent ni français ni anglais
la famille c'est on ne sait pas encore
précisément ce qu'il adviendra du site
vendu le développeur immobilier et
hopper capello assure qu'il n'y a aucun
projet planifié et que tout projet futur
prendrait fortement en considération la
très riche histoire du voisinage
entre-temps québec et la ville de
montréal lance un comité de travail afin
de trouver des moyens de préserver
l'identité du quartier chinois
tout sera examiné ou encore une fois oui
le quartier change et se développe mais
il faut pas perdre larmes mais il en a
déjà perdu une bonne partie selon
héritage montréal il ya eu des nouvelles
constructions qui se sont faites sans
nécessairement que ce soit qui ait une
volonté de préservation puis de
protection puisse à lui mis à mal le
quartier puis bon an mal an ben il ya eu
des pertes incroyable puis l'on se rend
compte que pays il restera plus rien ne
justifiait pas un effort qui est fait le
groupe de travail sur le quartier
chinois espère que les actions viendront
rapidement voir d'ici la fin du mois de
juin
car le secteur est très convoité une
reconnaissance patrimoniale aiderait à
la préservation du
artix et à mieux contrôler le
développement il si mélissa françois
radio canada montréal